back on
correct we're good to go thank you
um uh so look i'd like to uh move to the
recommendations we have them in front of
us
um as a member prepared to move these
motions thank you rangi do i have a
second to please
thank you graeme is there any discussion
on the motions
uh sorry
ah graham you've been demoted oh sorry
sorry nice try
[Music]
so um there's any discussion on the
motion it's been a it's a long it's a
long afternoon it's a long series of
motions but i think we've gone through
it recently okay
i'll put the motion then all those in
favor please say aye
those against
it's carried
so look that brings as far as i'm aware
uh the meeting to a conclusion but it
would be remiss of me not to
um firstly uh thank you derrick um
you've mentioned this has been done
professionally
and
that we have a
a suitably strong relationship
and thank you for saying that i think
that's important to us to know that it's
the case
i know that you need to have a good
break along with your team so i do wish
shewell
i would though like to leave the last to
clear
michael patricia and their team
i think the quality has improved
substantially since i've started here
with the committee
and
the confidence that i've had in your
general
work that you've brought to the
committee let alone the annual report
this year has been uh light years ahead
of i think we've been in the past so i'm
incredibly grateful to everybody claire
looking away as well
for the hard yards that you guys have
done to enable the committee
to function and i'm most impressed that
we have ultimately got to this point
with the annual report so i'm deeply
grateful and i think i'm correct and
passing it on behalf of the committee
and graham people that then thank you
for staying for people that have people
that have
stayed with the committee so thank you
to all of you and
uh it's my final good duty to wish you
all very merry christmas with your
family and a great break rangi um and
i'd like to to say i'd like to thank the
chair for his work too a great
improvement on the previous chair thank
you
that's it
magnus thank you from you ranging this
lovely so look uh given the state given
you still got a meeting to go i'd like
to declare the risk and assurance
committee meeting uh extraordinary risk
and assurance committee meeting closed
thank you very much
um
thank you mr chair and we now need to
reconvene counsel
your worship do you wish to do it to
come back here or do you wish to do it
from where you are
i can do it from where i am
[Music]
so you'll need to reconvene
there we go thank you
thank you
all right
sit down
wait till i leave yeah it's
oh it's okay
i'll reconvene the meeting counsellors
yes it is you're receiving the
recommendations from risk and assurance
and confirming them
okay
so your worship i'm happy to
move that we
receive and confirm
the recommendations recently received
from the risk insurance committee
around the annual report
i'd like to second that
moved and senator discussion
questions
issues counsellors need to feel they
need to raise
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against
and carried it feliz navidad
you can close the meeting soon oh
gee it is quickly
reconvened the meeting
to clear the meeting close don't worry
thank you
you